[Music]
you
that's like my name is caleb envy and
stepping in for our Cobian is Archbishop
International Master Dorsett Derek Shani
and will be here to give you all the
coverage for today's games the games are
just about ready to get underway so why
don't we take a quick look at where we
stand in the division and see what we
have to look forward to today so the
Canada chess bras are our opponents
today and they stand first place in the
Western Division with 85 points
ranking we'll be hoping to turn around
today and we can turn around with a
victory in today's match and we are
second place with 81 and a half points
and then trailing us are the New York
Marshalls and the California unicorns
two teams which we've actually already
faced and already beaten so this is
going to be the key matchup for us here
today and of course the format for the
protest League this year is game in ten
minutes with a two second delay that is
down from game in 15 minutes last year
there are twenty four teams and the
protest League split into three division
seven of the top ten players in the
world are in there and I think we have
quite a number of those on our team
alone teams from four continents it's a
global chess league and of course the
teams are fighting to get into the Final
Four which will be played at a live
final with players in person against
each other but still playing on of
course chess comm maybe we can take a
quick look at what our pairings are for
today of course we are facing the Canada
chess pros and they have four
devastating players on their team
although maybe not quite as devastating
as as our players of course
Alexander Grichuk is their board one
world renowned player he's been at the
top of the top of the game for years and
years now 2777 current rating and number
two for the Canada chess Bros is
actually ali reza firoozeh
who is a very up-and-coming player from
iran and he's been putting together some
very impressive results particularly in
the first half of Tata Steel this year
he was being very stormy yeah scoring
some wins against some some legendary
players and of course he's an online
chess specialist so he's one to look out
for and now board three for the chess
bras is Ivan Sarich who used to be board
one for the chess bras and on that board
one position he actually scored quite a
number of points and led the chess bras
to numerous victories and of course the
original chess bra Eric Hanson rounds
out their team on board for just over
twenty six hundred and our team needs
little introduction
Fabiano Cara wanna on board one Leni a
Dominguez on board to Wesley so on board
three and our free agent Lee M Lee on
board for all over 2,700 bringing up our
average rating to well over twenty seven
fifty at 2764 so definitely we are the
favorites in this match although perhaps
this is the one team that could give the
archbishop's a challenge I thought that
we were Jeffrey was going to be stepping
in uh yeah these are our top four
players of course Jeffrey just a couple
points below the in we're talking about
having Jeffrey and is like well we do
have a very strong first world war there
yep should get the job done
this is definitely our a-team I don't
want waste too much more time so the
games are underway so why don't we just
jump into the actual chess here yeah of
course
in the first round board one plays
against board four so this is our board
one fabi against board for for the chess
brows Eric Hanson
yet we have royal Pez I'm a big fan of
this d66 to see this so black it's
castles yeah so far I like it all
everything going great
oh you see how much space black has just
10 11 moves in the game it feels so much
empowering because you know in the
normal like their normal is already like
in East 7 you don't really know what
you're doing with this this knife is
either a v8 or an a5 and you're still
trying to push for c5 yeah but by
clearing the c7 square the knight has a
much more natural home like if white or
to like have this pawn somehow magically
close up the center then black woods
have a King side attack once the Queen
side is also under control so yeah I
like this very much okay so we have a so
yeah the D file opens yeah I think
something moves such as like Queen c7
should be coming up in the next few
moves yeah everything's super normal
super logical and if this nice were to
get exchanged it's still pretty nice
this special here could be in a better
position but also the position is very
closed up yeah and it supports the
center directly with E 5 and kind of
indirectly with the d4 square and maybe
at a much later date
some pieces get traded off and black can
kind of expand with f5 and trying to
push efore to open the bishop and so
this is our composition i I think
Fabriano has got this one this this is
this is
very nice positional games and yeah he
also has about two almost three minutes
more so yeah yeah of course throughout
the process we've seen Fabi always up on
time so you know he definitely plays the
time control the way it's meant to be
played fast and and you know yeah
threatening chess
okay so chest that that makes his
opponents I really spend their time and
you really get down on the clock fear is
just games firoozeh
okay also plays recently in toughest
yeah and I believe Wesley actually was
the first player to stop through his hot
streak he defeated him and I think a
Queens gambit accepted I dunno that's
why we do videos him cuz that was a game
that I wanted to do I think you took it
first I'm sorry okay so far everything
is logical no pieces are hanging so this
is actually pretty similar to to how
Wesley actually beat firoozeh in Tata
Steel just simple chess the open sea
files and open D files but and then
Wesley managed to in the Tata Steel game
just maneuver his pieces a bit better
and create some uncomfortable threats
for black so that's probably what he's
aiming to do here as well it feels very
nice my one question is where do you
want this Bishop to be do you want to
like maybe would be three push should be
to like ideally yeah that's something
you can't do it right now but the is
that something like where would this
Bishop want to be well in the game I
think Wesley actually picks g5 for the
bishop which makes a lot of sense g5
really puts pressure on the e7 bishop it
it's a little bit kind of awkward to
maneuver the black pieces and this is
what it may actually saw on the tata
steel game as well and perhaps cruisers
getting getting some flashbacks of where
his pieces just don't seem to
fit onto the board I mean good for us
but worrisome for the chest yet perhaps
Perugia is actually having some
technical difficulties here and that's
why he's he's a little bit down on the
clock I mean I'm not complaining but
it's yeah it's it's a pity that players
cans play to their best yeah okay how's
our board to doing Linea Dominguez
against the veteran chess bruh
Ivan Suraj I would believe that I like
this age 392 I find it very few times
but it always was so so interesting and
yeah I kind of like to keep working on
the center but you don't really you
can't really get your Bishop to c4 in
time usually so it's a good idea to have
something like this so of course black
has to spend some time playing h5 to
prevent g4 and 93 ideas and white uses
this time to get the bishop to g2 to
control t5 a little bit more the other
thing is like when there's b5 he usually
a four is the way to answer in a long
run right because you kind of want to
make the C word as pawn stance they want
to push it if you take it then a six
pawn is a little dance weak
alright so so far I like it all yes so
f4 is how white breaks in the center
yeah but I feel like it might have been
a little too early for f4 I don't know
like if I were white I would probably
try to move my Queen first a little see
where I want this night and then trying
to push for f4 but
well maybe the knight wants to jump out
to the f4 square and so it says I need
to to kind of support that's it after f4
what are you gonna do I actually went
take it yeah maybe maybe not maybe I'll
play g4 though and start to start really
pushing I'm not sure and again they did
it take it okay okay oh yeah take
tactically you can't take of course
there's there's d6 and this question
hitting the bishop on e7 as well as the
rook on ahead okay I think I get it
better now yes so the knight does come
into d4 black does try and trade off
these dark squared bishop but wait any
like big threats
except for this maybe 96 what is that
like a it's not a determining factor
yeah what like that flame isn't getting
checkmated here yeah and that I I have
to say I do like the placement of blacks
bishops here they control a large
portion of the board and c2 is actually
under some pressure yeah um the other
thing that I kind of wanted to say is do
you do well I kind of feel like black
shirts be doing shorts Castle but it's
um it's a little discipline h5 isn't
really helping my decisions took me
Castle right and and this is part of the
point of whites opening plays is playing
h3 and kind of baiting black into
playing this move h5 it can often turn
out to be a little bit of a weakness
that black is now having to keep track
of and so how did the game continue here
96 wait
yeah yeah I you don't want this monster
poem to be up here and then d6 piece
path week definitely not okay so far so
good
I'm just talking why can't we know why
it's taking this perhaps he could but
then maybe there's Bishop f6 in the ends
and there's some threats to be too and
I'm not sure that the D pawn is actually
improved like the pawn on d5 might
actually turn out to be a little bit
more weak without the pawn on d6 to kind
of block out the black pieces yeah I
like that I like this f6 plenty is
choice to maintain the knight on e5 yeah
the Knights have kind of it's a good
idea to keep it on e5 mm-hmm but this is
not ideally what I wanted to see because
even though this Bishop does serve a
purpose it would be much nicer if it was
you know in the actual game right yeah
white is kind of just making this bishop
into a little bit of a a ghost by if if
white doesn't use the the square Z 3 D 2
or C 1 then the bishop is controlling
kind of thin air
yeah it's not really serving a purpose
so after you've got exchanged now the
beef sub e5 pawn is under attack whoops
and
and so yeah we we actually see a ton of
trades and players approach an endgame
here so now I think I made the big
question is is this Bishop Ward's this
knight or vice versa it's a difficult
question and I think it's a question
that is changed by whether or not that
the Queen's are on the board
which is why I'm pretty sure black went
for a queen trade pretty quickly here
nice and so now that the Queen's off the
board I think I do actually prefer
blacks Bishop to White's night yeah with
the Queen's on the board of course the
queen of the night kind of do work well
together and you could have seen some
threats around the black king if if
black hadn't managed to to trade off
these Queens so quickly here though I
think I like I like black a bit more
probably it's it's not a crushing
advantage or anything I'm expecting
maybe a draw from this game but I'm not
sure - but I feel like living here is
gonna have the upper hand even when it
ends in a draw but I like the overall
progression in this game absolutely and
then I think yeah board
Liam Lee against chris scherk has
actually progressed pretty Wow there's
some definite similarities to the last
and however I think this one might be a
little bit more preferable for white
than the previous position we looked at
the pawn on a4 is a little bit weak and
white is gonna have to keep track of
that but at the same time the white
knight on c6 is is going to stay there
and I think it's going to be a little
bit more relevant than the Black Knight
or the white knight we saw in the
previous game and this plot actually
comes to a5 and the further up the board
this pawn gets the more threatening it
actually becomes there is kind of a kind
of a rule that I've heard where the
further up aboard the further up the
board the pawn gets the the more it's
kind of worse that's because these
closer and closer to threatening to
become a queen and so your opponent has
to really keep a closer eye on it in so
from a 5 you can imagine this pawn very
easily gets to ace
six with the help of this LightSquared
bishop but then getting through a seven
might be a little bit more difficult
when are we gonna play like Cooksey
seven rookie seven okay and then right
now but I kind of really want to have
the truck on e7 and have my queen on c4
without worrying about the first wreck
what why not rookie seven right now
though maybe Queen b5 check yeah I guess
Queen b5 here there's some some tactical
well I wanted to play a Bishop e2 and
then I thought your queen was trapped
and I was worried for a moment about
Knight takes d5 but I think I can just
take your queen and there's no 93 check
because my rep covers it so what is yeah
I'm not sure what black does after Ricky
seven it's a little bit confusing yeah I
mean 7 is always a threat and it's not a
bad idea to try and open some room
before they came to breathe yes so g3
gives gives the King a little bit more
space of course the dark squares are not
safe for that white King with that
Bishop on c5 but g2 seems to be a fairly
nice home and I guess Rick e7 black
could play could play queen c8 although
it seems a little bit a little bit shaky
so that is a quick look at all four of
our boards why don't we jump back to the
game of Wesley so against ali riza
freesia because it looks like Wesley is
putting on quite a bit of pressure on
first Wow
yeah Fraser of course might have had
some some technical difficulties there
you did get back to the game eventually
but I'm not sure how much time he
actually lost in the long run and now
Wesley seems to be up a clean pawn with
more active rooks and we'll be looking
to to convert this game oh I'm thinking
I don't think and that's why he actually
lost time because like he was thinking
for about three and a half minutes
somewhere
another almost two minutes somewhere yes
so I mean it doesn't sound like too much
but five minutes it's actually almost
like half of his time so if a lot of
that was spent dealing with connection
issues that's it's a little bit
unfortunate for firoozeh but here I
think Wesley has definitely outplayed
him regardless yeah yeah I agree the
ropes on the seventh rank and the one
more pawn it's I think this game is
pretty decided yeah of course the time
control is ten plus a two second
increment and all four boards play at
the same time so we've got four games
going on right now it looks like we
actually have a results in one of the
games Oh on board one Bobby has actually
drawn with Eric Hanson's not quite there
is what we were hoping for here well
yeah but I'm trying to figure out where
it went a little out of hand because the
final position
well Bobby kind of it's a series he
called draw yes oh but Bobby's of course
on the worse like this is a theoretical
end game so we should take such the tree
is not a blunder yeah the point is that
the right on of the wrong color is
always yeah but it did get a little bit
a little bit scary there I guess for
foggy just down on a clean pot in the
Sun again we were somewhere around here
when he left off and I thought it was
gone pretty smoothly maybe i rerouted
perhaps this Bishop on g7 is actually a
little bit more of a problem than we
were giving it credit for it does come
back to f8 but now the white pieces are
starting to invade an opponent e5 simply
felt its yeah so Eric getting getting it
a little bit the better of Bobby there
but Fabio holding off in that endgame
why don't we keep a keep an eye on these
games they're still in progress though
cuz I only came because their boats in
like
time trouble but great trick isn't it
yeah real time trick down to 18 seconds
of course lamely a little bit of a time
edge with over 2 minutes still in the
clock and I really like this position
for white I think this pawn on a5 is
just going to be a nagging threat that
black will have to always keep an eye on
and this knight on c6 but I don't see a
way to get rid of it so definitely a lot
to play for here with the white pieces
and this move rookie 7 still looks looks
threatening of course you don't want to
allow any 93 stuff so why does have to
respond to this threat may be simply
Queen c3 defends the e3 Square and gets
24 if it's doable yeah I like Queenie 4
but I do want to keep the e-file open so
I can play this Riki 7 move I really
like this move but if Queen Ivoire then
you're attacking the knight so the
knight has to do something and then you
could think about Queenie 7 try to
exchange the Queen's off without mines
off the board you you're you have one
more plan and it kind of seems a bit
more clear that knight on c6 is really
strong black doesn't really have a
counter play so what I like about Queen
c3 is I think it actually does a lot of
what you were saying
Queenie 4 does we can see 3 I think is
actually making a threat to the night
because Ricky 7 will force this Queen
off of its natural square where it
defense and moves like Queen f5 aren't
really playable do this Knight East 7
idea and so I think I like getting this
this trick in here while treating Queens
gets you closer to that end game you're
talking about
I think the black Queen is awkward
enough that it makes more sense to kind
of push it around a bit more but
definitely there's a lot of ways to move
forward with white here I think
everything is pretty good just make a
move yeah oh my god he hasn't moved in
two men oh yeah we're chatting away but
it Queen c3 Queenie 4 there's there's
plenty of options so Queenie for Lee
only does go for but now o'night f2 and
97 check this is looking a little bit
strange now there's Queen h3 threats to
look out for so Queen f5 gets rid of
this happy news
hanging I think I think things have gone
slow take on 85 can they take on d6 can
take on d6 that's 93 Whateley on 93 then
9th jumpstart for checking them to show
d6 I guess yes so we see 93 and seven
and this pawn does does fall some
tactics there to look out for the Sun
game shouldn't be horrible for white but
it's definitely black whose favorite now
which is rather unfortunate something
something went wrong there I guess
there's some tactical threats we didn't
really notice after after 24h 5 is nice
though and this is looking to be pretty
dead yeah Wesley so against Fallujah
here wait a second I'm waiting how did
it get yeah I'm very confused
I think Wesley is losing it took me like
a full ten seconds to comprehend which
way the pawns were going but this is
this like we were at it somewhere around
like no wait Wesley is white Wesley's
winning I couldn't yet sorry my brain
just couldn't process where which ones
were moving okay where's white is coming
up the board here and that is Wesley so
and so he's he's just winning in this
second so Wesley one Wesley ones for
little bits of time to Seaton what okay
we were uh why don't why don't we
actually come back to this game has
drawn against Chris Chuck and Linea
Dominguez is trying to win on the final
board here and it looks like he has very
good chances to this pawn on h4 will
will be running up the board quite
quickly and yeah he simply pushes after
King g3 this Knight cannot really guard
against the the pawn Queenie
it probably has to sacrifice itself or
it doesn't and now I think Lex simply is
queening me yeah well that was a very
nice first round so yeah Lenny a
dominguez actually winning on board too
and so after one round of plant
our board for actually drew their board
1 and their board for drew our board 1
but then we actually won on both boards
2 & 3 yeah that puts us to a full three
points to one lead after this first
round were there any games you wanted to
analyze yeah Wesley so again screws we
were somewhere around here and they were
talking you all come nice it is at this
industrial campaign right and I thought
it was kind of mmm
kind of already decided but it was
really interesting how black managed to
dig himself out of the hole if that's
what he did end up losing this game it
definitely started to look a little bit
more interesting yeah normal but I think
if we if we go through it I think Wesley
probably had it under control though I
mean it's nice yeah I want to pause here
and say in the second game it with pawns
on both sides of the board's White has
pawns on the Queen side black has pawns
on the Kings side it's not so much about
the number of pawns as the position of
the pawns and white spawns are much
further advanced up the board in this
case which is why Wesley is simply
winning here just by black collecting
slightly more pawns yeah I agree I feel
like if this pawn like any of these two
pawns are black were slightly more
advanced we would have had a difference
difference yeah and so black does get to
advance the pawns but as we said the
white pawns are a little bit faster and
it's it's simply too late yeah it's so
interesting if like you make the Queen
now I can simply take it yes and now b7
you can't stop them both yeah yeah and
then the rest of it was pretty after it
okay for check everything was to come in
yeah it was all all pretty forced yeah
so that's Wesley so is big win we saw
Lenny a managed to win this endgame with
that Bishop very excellent technique for
him and I believe we're going to take a
short break and we might be back with
the one and only version of Cobian also
stay tuned
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about it after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
you through the city and discover the
music that gave the Blues their name at
the National Blues Museum Broadway
Oyster Bar or even the legendary
Blueberry Hill so whether you love the
Cardinals the Blues or the Blues come
play with us you guys know I can't play
this right st. Lou is always exploring
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art lay
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience is that you mr. me
we get your autograph of course I think
it's pretty cool that you love chess so
much we love chess to enjoy school chess
program and got to meet a real-life
Grandmaster I had this big one time I
put it please captain after school and
check my name in 27 moves Wow
I should be asking for your autograph
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including hello and welcome
back to week 5 of the protest sleek my
name is Caleb Denby and now dorsa has
been switched out for the one and only a
grandmaster version of Cobian hi guys
yeah bar it's it's good to have you here
have you been following the the league
very closely yes yeah I've been
following kind of you know I know that
this is our biggest match yeah of course
this is the the key matchup for us
against Canada chest press yeah
absolutely yes oh I'm glad we won the
first round
convincingly so hopefully we can win
this and finish first place yeah in our
division of course with the win here
today the st. Louis Archbishop's will be
launched in the first place in the
Western Division the chess bras are
really the only other undefeated team in
the division so they're the main
competitors here in fact why don't you
take a look and see the pairings for
round two to see what we have to expect
their board one Grichuk is playing
Wesley so our board three ali reza
firoozeh
moves on to face Lee Anne Lee Bobby Cara
wanna gets his chance against Ivan
Sarich and Lenny a Dominguez will be
taking on Eric Hanson so what do you
think the mismatches are here well ok
Greece shook Wesley so it's very close
match up I mean definitely Bishop is
also very strong a lot of history
between those two is fuchsia also very
strong and he had a tough game in the
first game I think that's to just all
play at him yes so that was a nice win
by Wesley so that's also toss-up in my
opinion so I think we have a clear
advantage another two boards that B&O
versus Sarich and linear versus
handsome so if everything goes well we
should be able to get two and half a
place in this match all right so I mean
you know I really think our Fabiano and
Lanier would be I definitely agree
there's something to be said though you
know I even of course lost in round one
as did Faria as you said so there's
there's something about the psychology
yeah where they don't have a very long
of a break here between rounds and I'm
gonna have to bounce back Eric Eric
actually had some some advantage she was
off upon again I'll be honest maybe some
chances to press as one to look out for
looking at the game yeah so we'll see
yeah this is a critical match because if
we win this match basically I think
eight eight and a half is the magic
number of course it's eight and a half
you win the match and you get ten bonus
Emily yeah so I think if we win this
match so I think it's going to be a very
very close that we will just win you
know without much difficulties because
if even we get right in half here so
we'll be at five and a half points
mm-hmm so and there will be just at you
know half yeah it very very quickly gets
into a situation where they would be
needing just like sweep our team in the
rounds and you just can't do that
against this line yes so you've yeah so
let's let's wait until the results for
this one but I think you know got a
comfortable advantage of course
important to note we are fighting the
Shastras for first place in the Western
Division and the team that does get
first place in the division actually
gets a bye in the first round of the
playoffs so definitely a lot to play a
very important yeah so so first place
will basically have extra you know they
would have they don't have to play that
there's one few one fewer matches that
you have to win and in a knockout format
that's actually critical it's it's one
less chance for your players to mess up
verse 14 is qualify yes so the first
four teams in each division do qualify
and then I believe that fifth place team
one gets in based on their performance
rating in the division
I'm not sure on that format exactly
luckily we don't have to worry about it
too much because we're gonna be and we
got some moves already here so we have
moves in the game this shook against
best is so so Wesley let's see Bishop
before so we have a row goes in of
course and the question is okay I'm
going to take take the ship c5 one of
the main lines and h6 fish page four
interesting
so of course Bishop h4 and Bishop takes
f6 there are two of them absolutely yeah
so Bishop h4 keeps pieces on the board
it's a little bit more combative than
the fish it takes yes this is all theory
action it's been a pretty popular lately
the black just gives up the bishop but
apparently just you know it's about
equal it's not that much so quick c5 b5
yeah with ideas you know maybe at some
point even Queen a5 yeah and this ponen
b7 does look undefended but it's not
worth the time to cap yes yeah
absolutely the King in the middle is
probably too risky yeah there could be
some ideas that group b8 it'll be two of
them yeah no he takes d5 is a little
surprising to me actually yeah the only
idea behind it is just to be able to put
a knight on d4 so that's why taking on
c5 so it does look like it kind of ruins
the pawn structure but the point is to
put a knight on d4 if white can
establish some kind of you know a
position where he has the two bishops
and knight on d4 let's say pawn on a
street and he may claim a slightly
better position alright but it's not
gonna be that easy to do so some ideas
of 93 maybe here yes yeah I'm not sure
if we can we came out to make analysis
move yeah so yeah 93 in this variation
probably would have result in two
there should be three Bishop d3 and yeah
maybe then why some h4 yes mhm for ideas
because then you know pressure on g g5
so i think they tell you basically
they're in like that so 94 so the point
here is at some point you're gonna have
to eliminate the docs permission that
a very important piece the visual ninja
- so you have to kind of be in a
situation where you can take that bishop
and so let's see now
yeah I like the patience Wesley is
showing though just putting his pieces
on good squares and keeping his options
yeah and also be should be fire doesn't
quite work we should be fire Bishop
before because you're gonna run into
chief or IG for just removing the
defender of the bishop and so this is
our current position yeah
and so yeah a lot to think about here
for Gretchen I probably just bring the
risks to the center there's to the B
file as well
yeah they are playing very fast I mean
if you just look at ago they've played
15 moves already yeah and they almost
are in about a minute which is which is
you know remarkable very very fast so so
that's more maybe take a look at another
game yeah I think all four of them are
in progress there on the side perfect so
let's take a look at this game so here
we have the quandary am against fuchsia
so this is a marine defense so yeah and
it looks like the kind of the main line
where you going on the onion yeah I mean
you know the quagga is a very very
strong in-game player and you know yeah
definitely at home and or looking at a
clock you can tell that you know what I
want is just comfortable theory she's
not so sure he's not completely sure at
the moment black actually has a threat
taking on f3 I'm playing 94 yeah of
course that would be devastating to the
white coalition move like c3 needs to be
considered I know can i g5 please
stepping out of that the f3 threat okay
it's like how was he gonna defend now C
- I mean this is though this is actually
a very good question is it counting only
six I mean buddy 6e six maybe if there's
f6 y 6f6
I'm not sure where the threat is for for
white knight they're serving just G yeah
Ritchie eight and then you can even play
e7 but after Bishop e7 there's no real
way to add more more pressure than
sufficient I'm not sure what future is
doing here because it seems like he
might just be
close to be lost here I mean 96 also for
well 96 I even have rook h6 maybe
breakage 6
maybe there's night f8 and then great I
know there is some kind of discovery but
it's gonna because yeah I can also go to
g6 there and the pressure on Zito right
my roof might be actually quite useful
it looks slightly scary but I guess he's
7 ok now there's 96 after after a threat
maybe but can we just capture I guess we
can't capture on g5 because then it
takes on that fate and a g6 will come
interesting ok so if we just take
everything I wonder what would happen
here if we take one g5 if if it takes on
a fade we go King f8 96 check King f7
yeah
takes on h8 rotate sheet at the end of
that line still the c2 pawn is not
defendable right white would be an
exchange up in that position now yeah
definitely there's some another idea
here is possibly after taking on g5 96
he could play 96 first so what if we
actually take on e7 I think this is the
line that can call me servicing actually
6 and I'll take on on g5 v rookie 7
chicken 88 fish sushi 5 that looks
dangerous
a little bit scary so maybe perhaps
fuchsia had seen deeper then yeah then
we did yeah well this laQuan maybe did
miss 6 causing some very serious
problems yeah this is not easy
her nose is fully kuang so so again it's
okay can we take on c2 or keep it a
constitute then he takes on f8 check we
don't have a way to make this analysis I
don't believe that okay
sorry yeah so tonight see let's see what
will happen if we take okay takes no
yeah it doesn't see an AC - takes a nice
she - perhaps but takes on their faith
can take say faith is forced 96 seems
pretty forced kingi a it only move okay
White has a draw we should not that
night Lisa right wife is enthroned a
pocket but especially with the mass
situation you know what we gonna have to
play for a winner every draw is good for
us the match situation every joy is good
for us basically I mean as long as we're
maintaining that 2-point cushion so okay
so we actually do see night take see -
and I think I agree didn't I see -
what's the most most challenging line so
how does this line so we take on f8 King
f8 96 seems like the move King g8 and
then what is there really for white you
can take on H a but then Knight take c1
whoa yeah well that's the whole thing I
think illa because the point of 92 is
when you play 96 now yeah you don't have
that strong threat of it takes F a check
because I can take the rook on e 1 of
course if you take on I fit I have rook
takes afraid so in 1960 first definitely
not not gonna I just it doesn't work so
I don't know if there is anything better
than taking actually I don't think
rooky - rookie - we can't even come back
with 94 if we really want to be annoying
you know attacking the rook right
because I don't think you'll have an
squares on the e-file a6 is covered for
is covered and you only have you won any
three available Nike just keep playing
annoying with this nice [ __ ] - no you
would not see - so Anarchy theory it
might be worth noting that but then this
kind of blocks the the bishops are
develop it yeah yes take on a faith King
takes a fate
okay there are some other options such
as night
night fe6 check okay
King f7 mmm something like Bishop d2 but
yeah I'm not sure we will not even have
to be in hurry to take any of the rules
because they're still fourth right so we
have additional also that that line is
actually probably very dangerous to go
for your white because after we take the
rook in that line we still have route
and to pass so we have sufficient
compensation so I think most likely take
take night g6 King g8 does he have he
can he play something like rookie 7
there okay okay not sure if we're about
to find out we're about to find out
absolutely so Rickie 7 there I don't
know if there's actually a threat idea
96 96 threatens with defense and see if
I should take the knight or take the
rook on any one question I like taking
the night it just gets rid of an
attacker and then the rookin a rookies
rookies still on pre so and then things
like Rick h6 are also going to this this
is the wild one yes this is a really
really wild one guys I mean this is just
like yeah this is I don't think Felucia
is gonna go for a draw
no definitely lost the first game and I
mean three one down I don't know I
he's a fighter I think he's gonna try to
go for it obvious I'll be slightly
surprised if he goes for the perpetual
again he can make a draw here guys with
96 [ __ ] kingi 897 check King f8 and just
forced a job but I don't think I don't
think he's gonna do that he might he
might take a chance here but again but
this might work out even better for us
because he might be over pressing yeah
with the pressure that we put on a new
one getting this lead definitely the
Tres brows are going to be looking to
play a very competitive combative chess
and maybe take some risks that they are
yeah but he want is a nice nice lead
here so yeah this is I want you to
decide in this game I think actually
Lenny and Dominguez has a very
comfortable position against Eric Hanson
that I'd like to take near Domingues
let's see here
near Domingues white again this night on
a five versus the special bond on e6 and
better for linear night Bishop is strong
stronger than tonight first of all night
is misplaced
there's some serious could be some
serious issues with the King here as
well of course and also by the way move
like ninety six doesn't solve your
problems Bishop d5 if they should be
fine don't think exchange there 97 yes
this is very very nice let you see how a
linear managed to get such a nice
position out opening I mean II for so
this is a reuleaux pace so linear is
very well-prepared in theory so yes
surprise that resistor that's that's one
of the huge advantages of these 2,776
better prepares in opening agree yeah so
you know you may think like what's going
on the bishop on a2 is blocked but the
problem is white wants to play d4 very
quickly and and again ninety stuck on
the room right so and yeah we saw that
night in the current position yeah
absolutely not this is clearly clearly
better not for white strong knight on d4
pawn on d5 submission f6 and now that's
pretty that's very pretty nice tactic
and now gaining the control the last
could be seven threat is devastating so
has to move the bishop has to move the
King first to prevent the thread and now
Bishop e6 planting the bishop in Queen
h5 coming up Bishop f5 is a deadly
threat here by the way yeah you have to
do something about it
h6 Bishop h6 wins so he had to do
something Bishop before Bishop e3 and
that's how we got here look afraid
consolidating rook on eight and we won
not in the game so he just consolidated
and see if I was played Bishop b5
beautiful move cutting up the night now
Knight it's just caught off and
desperately wants to come back into the
game that's why Eric played rook c8 to
be able to call [ __ ] 96 and now a
linear that move hurts to see yeah the
point of this move is if you take on b2
now Bishop before it's going to come in
with a threat of h7 hanging and
jeez six it d6 is sitting in as well I
mean what what does black even play here
like weena five I suppose Queen I five
well I think then justjust take the
cookies yeah it's when when this so very
nice technical game by a Dominguez here
he's a head on a clock he's I think he's
just winning here I don't think he's
gonna let this one slip I tend to agree
and actually you only a little bit of a
surprise Emily has officially drawn
forges oh oh that's what happened okay I
did go feel a little bit of a surprise
but okay
we'll take it right yeah as we said we
can definitely start drawing it
absolutely everything every drop brings
us closer to that magical number eighty
eight point five see now wait three and
a half of course three and a half points
not a good result so let's take a look
see what fabi doing we haven't looked at
his game yet so he's playing sorry yeah
so yes and we have some sharp this looks
looks to be rather crazy yeah so this
was a sharp when I Dorf looks like so
okay very sharp okay so very sharp
neither of h3 so all our Sonic's lost
the first game so he's yet determined to
a lots of pretty get some points 96 came
in also you find interesting that Fabi
is Cal so long and also playing on that
side trying to fix yeah you know there's
the rule don't touch the pawns in front
of you but in this case Bobby is
actually preventing black from
absolutely is pressing here because now
you cannot they be five yet concretely
okay you gotta watch out for looks at
Rideau of course locking just ready to
take and play Bishop c6 there should be
six years another queen defense
laterally into 5695
and for and now that interesting age for
blacks can lock down on the Queen side
and Fabia tries in a lot of okay if I
was hanging also sacrifice a pawn g5 by
sorry a for how my goodness stuff what's
happening to him
Bishop f2 I don't know so if Bobby is
sacrificing many pawns now but down
three okay three right she's down three
but she died my goodness what's going on
here Bishop g5 okay so that makes four
pawns for puns down okay up back up to
three back up three just just for those
93 is important because it prevents
tonight at five definitely look see five
look afraid okay so some dress to see to
but it takes a net my work I'm worried
about for Fabi here two guys I feel like
gamble is Rick Dixie to move you're
threatening to play Queen me to mate of
course you can play the ship takes you
to but then Rick takes again I take a
look before I guess they take rook
before but it seems to me I just it
seems very dangerous yeah I think he
just played very very risky you know and
yeah and I think this is something we've
actually seen from Fabi a little bit in
the protests leaked so far he really is
out to score full points yeah no matter
the risk and I think in the time
controller of 10+2 not Daisy it's it's
so fast that a lot of times both sides
are making a lot of mistakes we've seen
Fabi losing positions before but yeah so
yeah it's not over I mean with two
minutes on a clock I mean sorry she can
still make a mistake I mean objectively
I think is winning here right but not so
simple you know let's put it this way
not so simple here yeah I don't see who
should be played that dick mercy to and
I'm I'm not sure what else black can
really do this night on e3 is hanging so
if you don't clear accede to you have to
solve this problem somehow yeah you
don't want to play Knight take C 2
because then night
it would be a strong move I think I yeah
it's not easy
yeah I mean we're not under pressure and
we're looking at it we still don't see
that the exact way black any night
perhaps the good news for Fabia's is
Ivan like he's thinking here come on
you're still ticking trying to figure it
out yeah it's not the type of position
you can figure out in a minute
absolutely absolutely so all right so
let's maybe switch to so we have only
three games remaining so the best is so
game to see absolutely okay so vastly is
playing Greece shook so this is the game
that we had the ragas in see how they
got here we're expecting this to be one
of the closer match we're gonna be we
need to go fast a little bit because of
the time so we don't have that much time
for a very in-depth analysis here so so
this is where we left it off yeah 94 was
played 27 and c4 so you know Bishop
tries to get rid of the backwards pawn
and again West is gonna take that Bishop
at some point you cannot allow opponent
have to bishops so if we do see capture
and okay okay this is a problematic this
is not very good for blocking because
Knight is misplaced some weaknesses here
so brick is slightly better the e pawn
definitely more valuable than the beep
on here b6
okay the threat was Queen g6 the night
whites to come back into the game oh no
it goes back to e6 wieck is still a
little bit better killer because f4 is
coming yes so i don't know i still a
little bit unpleasant but it's another
five enemies as well it's ninety six is
six wait yes they calculated the Kingdom
Parliament game this is tricky because I
think the King and pawn and game should
be okay okay
at first glance yeah because the pawn is
not only the parmesan a4 it's probably
lost because you get fixed yes that's
actually a big big so you probably
calculate so again want one minute and
30 seconds remaining so it's not easy
for Greece sugar it's a big moment here
to make a decision what do you do here I
mean it's not easy there's a move Knight
F
five which could force Bishop versus
night I believe okay so he does take on
g6 instead and goes for this night end
game where the black pawn structures is
a quite a bit worse yeah yeah for
example if the palms on a for after
capture capture King before why would
you be winning okay if I would be
winning but now like I just enough
together captures check capture King D
for b5 I mean this needs to be
calculated Oh King c5 right it's oh and
perhaps it oh wow let's see now so what
if then we have a four for black instead
a for what a43 yeah I guess I can't
really waste my Leslie just mr. plate
miscalculated this as I was worried
about it you know I was worried about
that going to the same game okay is
there interesting yes so he does go for
a four but now a3 a3 is G for perhaps on
the cards for black geez this is idea to
try and yeah okay
take them g5 I have a lot of then I
guess b5
yeah I take and then I was trying to get
marched around to get but it seems like
by the time you take all this yeah I
think you miss plated cable it doesn't
look good it does not look as a problem
I think yeah okay so h5
he's preparing g4 maybe and then so also
he's also not he's trying to do this if
h4 he might take take and play g5 you're
giving him hit a certain age for j6h
Street and okay so keep looking for okay
that's not the move I expected
now now I move like b5 seems a lot more
reasonable to my eyes b5 came here take
take a tree King c3 taking p3 it's not
quite in time
I'm not quite in time okay so he can
he's gonna have to do something much
more important to note
Fabiano actually did manage to turn
around he's gone yeah that's Ivan and
has defeated look at that so that's
that's another point so we're at four
and a half right now yeah maybe we
should stay with this this game a little
bit longer than see how this one this
one yeah HD so I think this is the last
game kind of still in flux I will
mention Linea Dominguez does look to be
beating here being exerted by contract
Lee so this is there's a lot riding on
this one to be sure okay so okay so no
g55 this breaks up the the white pawns
I think there's to calculate yes
important to note that the H pawn if it
gets to H - it's the Troy it's a draw I
think it's a draw yeah and in fact it
looks like that might that done get my
not even it's a draw because yes who do
you want Kayla alright
what happens to be whack turtle any ace
game to see how this is wrapping up a
yeah so we've before oh yeah I thought
they finished it okay so she'll
important to note that night actually
never made it off the a v square just
went and picked it up with this ladies
up a full piece so the only issue is
just need to get rid of the c2 pond once
the c2 pond is gone this game is over I
would just I would just push the a pond
here if I was linear here traditionally
6 as well looks looks pretty play tricks
e8 as the nice little in-between move
now maybe a queen b7 okay
and yeah Bishop if that's right and pawn
is dead and so is the game where it
takes c2 and there's there's nothing ok
takes you to yeah that's queenly 5
centralize
there's no removing the defender tactics
that's it that's right this game is over
Lenny is up a full-piece perfect okay
this game is officially over
Lenny a has won and we do actually see
this Queen versus pawn endgame on the
board yeah Wow excellent is a dead drop
excellent okay excellent
yeah that's three two one two one again
round two now we can you know three to
one is very very huge win and now
basically between half
will clinch the match yeah the wrong to
go the score is six to two of course
eight and a half is all we need and we
have two rounds to score two and a half
points and so heroes for this round were
Fabiano and Domingues
yeah Fabiano and money hey are there any
guys yeah absolutely yeah it's Fabi turn
this oh yeah this was how he turned it
around because we thought it was really
dangerous so he did play Roxy - okay
yeah I think that was blacks best option
so we did see the game here and then
after rook f4 was when we were looking
okay so he did went for this before
again you know it's time situation if it
was not easy so Knight f3 now it's the
pressure on G 500 500 695 would be seven
yes favi just starts picking up somehow
Knight c3 there's no maid Queenie for
now sorry and oh oh now Queen c8 and all
of a sudden g5 that's that's a nice
sacrifice group takes f7 IG 5 fantastic
fantastic tactic yes with the idea of on
g5 for King the king of this oh wow how
quickly can turn around
very nice very very nice very nice that
key move rook takes g5 probably this
this was a blunder but maybe 93 trick I
don't know but yeah I don't know if it's
over just yet after it takes b7 it it
feels like black hasn't done enough
wrong to be dead last but maybe it's
just but it feels like it's shifting
yeah it is definitely shifting yeah so
yeah this was very nice in Domingues
he had a such a such a nice position and
I feel like Greece shook perhaps was
winning
yeah something felt wrong about this
anyway probably that's not allowed the
pawn to get on h3 I feel like here yes
maybe not like and I think Leslie
realized that here a 3 H 4 so here maybe
f4
f-for yeah you're actually totally
certain that or h3 now h3 is a very
cagey move so because if you play okay
but let's say you go here I go here you
have to play be fine
yeah so we get this position and so
let's see one two three four five six
one two three four I I think black is
still in time this pawn on f3 actually
don't yeah it's a bit of a shield yeah
for black black is in fact black is
cleaning work it's clinic first and
maybe we're trying to win Wow well maybe
it was yeah and again once again he
couldn't have played h4 we think because
of this this and this yeah of course
Wesley threatening to create tasks on
sample cells here and you are in the
square actually
but the problem after the capture f4 we
are in the square but there's the second
second second break comes in and and a
four point is further advanced that you
Queen actually first before blocking it
too quick
definitely so some very nice defensive
play for mostly soda to get the draw in
this game absolutely absolutely because
this is a very uncomfortable because
once f4 comes in this is very very
uncomfortable position actually well why
don't we take a quick look at the
results for round two and see where we
stand now of course the final score
after two rounds is six points for the
st. Louis Arch worships two points for
the condition did we know those two
boards remember we were talking about
yeah the the predictions were actually
absolutely right
Grichuk and firoozeh both playing Wesley
so and Liam Lee to it to a level game
ending in a draw and then those two
boards where we thought we had a slight
edge fabric Arowana and Lenny and
Dominguez both getting the job done
defeating their opponents in round two
like we said eight and a half is the
magic number just two and a half points
left to score in the final two rounds
should be a very easy task for these
four Incred
players on the st. Louis Archbishop's
with that of minds we are just waiting
for the next round to get underway here
why don't we take a look maybe at around
three pairings it makes absolutely yes
so we'll have those in just a moment of
course we need to win half points from a
possible game yeah it should be pretty
pretty easy to do I think yeah so
basically we need to yeah yes it's time
to start playing practical Cheska it's
getting some closer yeah and I will say
in rounds three and four that's where
this team has really had the biggest
advantage because our board ones I get
to play there they're hiring two players
and our board for is get to play they're
lower rated players and that's really
where the mismatch shows yeah but our
board three and four yeah yeah yeah we
saw him around - maybe on those first
two boards the chest brows they had a
fighting chance
but now as they start to move up towards
Fabi and 20s you see the ratings by the
way if you guys watching this is you
know who is watching this is fee their
ratings actually so yeah definitely
especially the average rating we have an
80 point Grichuk their board one now
plays our board too many a Dominguez le
Reza firoozeh has his shot against
Fabiano cara wanna their board one or
their board - in starboard one Ivan
search has to fight Liam Lee and Eric
Hanson will be taking on the one and
only Wesley so it's a very top but I
feel like this is situation for chess
prostituted a gonna have to go along
yeah this is definitely the round they
need to score as many points as possible
they need something like three three
it's like a twin distri want to even
have a chance you know I definitely
agree cause otherwise it's just gonna be
extremely difficult because yeah they
need to do but I don't know it looks you
know our team is playing really well and
we we haven't lost the game which is
always nice yeah that's that's very true
because it's harder to defeat you when
you're on the air for a while you know I
will say though it's not as though the
chess players haven't had any
chances they've definitely had some very
good positions but they just haven't
been able to take another shot each
against Fabiano felt like he yeah and
then even Eric Hansen against Bobby was
yeah up up a force on upon him he was he
was he was pressing Fabi
but he couldn't convert it so yeah this
is a big match so again we need to in
half points to clinch the victory and
and that will put us in a very good
position to be first yeah of course
there's only 7 weeks in the protest
League schedule this is week 5 and the
tres brows are the only other undefeated
team in the Western Division and so if
we defeat them here today with that ten
bonus points will be kind of launched
straight into the lead in the entire
western division and with some solid
play in the final two rounds for us I
think we're actually playing the Krakens
and the capybaras who are not having the
best season so it should be a slightly
easier pairings for us a little tart to
round out the season and and then we
should be long and again there those
teams are good they're all GM lineup but
they're not gonna have heavy eaters
phycology rule genre confusion sorry
this of course is next week's schedule
so if you want to join us at 10:30 a.m.
Pacific time that's 12:30 st. Louis time
here we are against Argentina Krakens
unfortunately we will not be doing live
coverage of that week as the Cairns Cup
will be going on but you're welcome to
follow along live chats calm should be
doing a stream for it and you can follow
the games for yourself Alan chess comm
follow our top players as they they take
on the Krakens well we're just waiting
for round 3 to get underway here and
possibly this could last I mean maybe
that would still play that they still
play of course your actual match score
is what counts for Division standings
each point that you score and the match
goes towards your total score and then
of course with the win you get ten bonus
points added on and if we if we get to
eight in half we get to ten bonus points
yes and plus so if you get to eight and
a half your score goes eight
2:18 and a half but then every point you
score beyond eight and a half still gets
added to your score and we definitely
could use that extra buffer as the chess
pros have shown right handle loss at the
moment there they're actually a few
points up and they've been maybe
slightly better a couple of big matches
yeah scoring or kind of running up the
score against the the weaker weaker
seems that's where they've kind of
excelled but now against against the
real deal they're going a little bit
absolutely yeah yeah the round three is
about start and yeah it's for chess plus
it's a must-win situation they need to
win a match and I need to win it big
they need to win like three games so if
they win both matches let's say you know
they still not gonna be it's not gonna
be enough yes we will have nine points
anyway even if they score like two and a
half points in both rounds we're going
to win the match no we don't match they
News at 9:00 to 7:00 they need something
close to it to us so we are at +4 you
know in the chest language so we're plus
four right now so they're gonna need to
equalize get four wins somewhere and now
lose any yeah of course just want to
take a look and see how Lenny a managed
to convert this game against our cancer
I think that's the one game we kind of
have in fully taken so we left off when
you had a complete domination after yeah
we have this six move yeah rookie six
and g6 you six cameras so okay okay
Blaine you probably could have just
taken on f6 taken on these six - yeah
that end games totally winning it's
tough to count the number of advantages
White has here this this efile also
proven to be very relevant yeah the
problem is the King is also a week here
yeah so it's like you're dominating and
also the there issues with the King and
yeah this night is actually just totally
trapped on 85 and okay so that's how we
we arrived at the position on the board
just a few accurate was not a good night
became a decisive factor in this game
yeah because the knight moved a five in
the opening and never stayed there and
never yeah that's an example for you
guys seen a knight on the rim and just
never came back okay
very very accurate at the end also
linear just just just only think if just
to see two pawns to just have to
eliminate it
and you just managed to do that perfect
all right so so I guess they have a
little bit longer break I guess I think
that's like a half it's a little bit of
a half behind huh so I think though the
game should be getting anyway before too
much longer we we've been talking for a
while so they must be close to getting
underway there we go we got it the games
again just started so again linear
against Trish soup again super solid in
years
yeah my weight linear did he win the
first game too or I really well I think
he did when he's already Haiti here in
this match sorry yeah oh yeah of course
those were around three pangs here we
have money against Chris Chuck yeah he
could start each and now he'd be ten
cents yeah research guys
that being said though this is this is
probably the board where yeah the chess
profs have the biggest chance to win
which is kind of crazy to say against
plenty of Dominguez that's going to
points already but this is this is where
they need to make it happen and this
looks like some more opening theory I
denied Dorf
I mean no surprise I'm angry shook is
not gonna play some Spanish or something
and expect he's gonna out there linear
so he's going for sharp stuff here I've
started a fast time control that so
that's what the protest League is about
so we see Knight b6 this d5 pawn under a
little bit of pressure how do you want
to deal with this maybe Queen a5 is as
possible but I was a possibility maybe
even there's some Knight a5 ideas
totally sure it's a c4 then yes she ate
before doesn't doesn't feel crazy for
with the king of c1 if my King was on b1
I wouldn't mind probably it's a little
bit a little bit easier to just follow
us in Queen before I can't play Knight
d5 here yeah
Bishop g5 might might be a possibility
as well and just taking some kinda you
can also I think give up the pawn a no
so he played support so I guess after
rook c8 líneas idea might be too
send you with queen bee what's the plan
if he just takes on c4 he just takes on
c4 look she got 9595 looks looks
challenging be 596 yeah we've seen this
Knight come to c6 numerous times again
he's one move away is this that King
won't be one yeah with the knight on a
five he's gonna have a nice grip on this
position and so crusher has to make
something happen now see also watch out
watch c5 at some point yes your five
braces work state was very natural and
we'll see his plan you know it was 9595
did you miss this it's slightly unclear
maybe after 95 Couric's player bunny is
planning to give up the bishop just play
King b1 and then the three Queen III you
know but if I say you're on time to take
these seven I guess it just looks
slightly strange to me I'm not sure what
the tactical justification is here
maybe Bishop g5 fish of g5 look looks
like a reason we'll move to me you're
just planning to to capture on f6 and
then 97 and 96 yeah so Bishop g5 yes so
that is actually the move we see again
why disparately needs to put the king on
b1 if he gets that it's just gonna be
very happy so and you know the position
opened up a little bit and that might
play into White's position because of
issues yeah and actually I think white
just might be tactically trying to win
d6 here
well now b7 is on pre d7 is on pre I
know you have to be carefull Bishop h6
stuff if you're white though you can't
get too crazy taking you're right all
right you need that king we want it yeah
you so many scenarios you need that's
okay so probably taking 97 ever inserted
maybe now Knight takes c6 and then King
b1 now taking advantage of the pen wow
this is some powerful play here yeah
very tactical stuff and Lenny a has done
it with using less than a minute on his
clock oh I mean this is this is unless
you wanna why's this otherwise happy you
bring so quick this is some very very
strange sometimes you know I guess if
you if you feel you know you
yeah you just you kind of play what
feels right and let your intuition guide
you
this is some very combative chess for
money a so the queen is attacked I
imagine black must play something like
Queen c7 or Queen d7 but then I think
Knight takes d6 is is White's idea
followed by king b1 so if so if Queen c7
here yeah so we're gonna take on this
series that's my plan and if Bishop
takes King b1 it's like the Sherpa
before yeah
as soon as possible maybe instead of you
think maybe instead of King b1 I'll play
Bishop takes f6
yeah and Queen d6 is my idea then we
trade and then I have six hanging that
they have yeah everything is everything
is like it's better there is okay that's
probably what he wants to do yeah
because if Queen c7 you try to go
prophylactic in b1
I think it just takes only seven and
then you take on d5 and yeah I'm not
sure that's that's what we're aiming for
here we should be saying block is up a
common factor yeah and the position
stays closed
you know White was you 100 percent
absolutely you have them when you have
the pair of the bishops you want to open
up the positions okay mystery Queen c7
and yeah Bishop f6 immediate ah is
actually his idea something some time
baby the knight takes Bishop h6 wait
Bishop h6 simply Bishop g5 back right
who takes ah there's 96 by the way you
have ah 96 I'll be 96 first million
should be five okay okay well Bishop g5
I just like playing Bishop g5 and then
because if Bishop g5 takes takes Queen
g5 Queen B so and then Queen d7 yeah but
you can have that position with the
Nidal sacrifice the knight on d6
interesting very combative chess as as
we've said and it's interesting that
Knight takes f6 96 anywhere you go with
a king I take on C it would check you
don't have time to play yes a King g7
it's a check otherwise actually which
page sixes yes submission 66 is now this
was gone White's way definitely this is
what for white slide I don't think it's
a crushing advantage or anything but
has navigated the applications and now
the rooks are on the open D file
yeah it's natural development on a lot
of weaknesses now Luke takes now yester
497 table should be to simply be to
where it comes to d1 and this is this is
a nice edge I think yeah there should be
two double the rooks double up the rooks
and at some point you want to play see
five years - yeah definitely not not not
super amazing before I still get a V 4 V
4 could get good control king bee -
maybe yeah I think we have to watch out
for a5 breaking because black might get
the a file to attack but you know even
sometimes just positions if you play b5
a 5 I mean we play B fire then this
Knight gets to c5 scores all right you
do have the problem on b6 but yeah I
think the problem is are with these yeah
I like b3 and ring King b2 we want to
get this bishop involved in the attacks
on how much okay so how can we activate
the white bishop here I think this is
gonna play a 5 mil yeah a 5 otherwise
because we want to produce exceed 5 in
Bishop a6 and then that would get the
bishop in the game so I think he knows
who plays g5 yeah in a 5 c5 anyway since
what I was about even takes he wants to
maybe you go like something like bishop
yeah I like Bishop b5 be fine and then
the this pressure to the page 6 will pay
for a physical get the a pawn back and
then start pushing a for something like
that do you know so c5 of course the
only way black could really take is as
pawn takes otherwise this will be now c5
is rook b8 go play yeah no longer we
have C Drive not so sure about this
maybe it was worth considering c5 right
here
c5 takes something like yeah there's
there's more than one way to get the
bishop into the game though I think
maybe uh maybe white is gonna play
something like rook d5 and Bishop d3 and
activate bishop in this manner
also there's some ideas of expanding
them on the kingside baby with g3 and f4
and then some some ideas of breaking up
the pawn structure in that way yeah okay
while we have little pause in this game
let's take a look at Aviano scheme
against Fallujah yeah I think this is
another key game for a wild game here
what's going on here so this is this
looks like a real opus with the capture
capture on c6 yes so okay so some
maneuvering going on here the
athleticals
is always very important knife comes to
e6 very tricky dispositions 96 comes in
it's the type of stuff that Fabi kind of
excels that yeah I mean by looking at
the whole block should be happy where he
is right I mean he's got everything and
consolidating it everything is developed
90 some differences of squares I will
say efficient a6 doesn't leave the best
impression yes my eyes but I think
that's the only problem here for black
rook e8 g4 and he placed nice to Kofi
Rosa firoozeh all right of course
Fabiana could have played DD 1 to
prevent all the sacrifices I don't know
anything but you probably didn't want to
play passively so you went here and
future goes for it you want to go g5 oh
right of course can't do nothing is
blank
these trees some solid now's the whole
position is colopsis ish yeah all the
white pawns we see getting taken off the
board but why does have this extra I
don't know I feel like the bishops are
so strong in the opposition though this
this black King isn't totally
comfortable on f7 we see we see G takes
f6 probably coming next
yes and then I look f2 and how does
black navigate the the complications
around this King I will say White's
extra nights not not looking very good
or a focus dropping to a no I think if
black is just winning here okay he can
just run I think just run but again
Fabiano it's always difficult tricky
I see nothing said very impressive
sacrifice from yeah absolutely yeah I
feel like I feel like you might have
underestimated this because maybe
something could have been done to
prevent this you know
yeah not leaving this truck enough one
for example yeah look one f2 or
something yeah that at least when you
need to sacrifice occurs it doesn't just
comes in with the temples you know right
no I mean remember we talked about that
bishop not very active but yeah Frieza
solves this problem with with a clever
sacrifice yes and now this is this is
tough okay so we can take on f6 yeah
okay six but it's not not actually this
was necessary because a for was hanging
- yeah he actually could have just taken
on a four and just run with the Kegel
she well I think his idea is is a Bishop
e7 in the near future is it time to play
something like maybe I can just play
Ricky one rookie want here yeah I guess
there's there's some b1 ideas that I
have to look out for but it's not
totally clear to me how Fabi is going to
navigate all the pressure on this King
as well as these these open bishops and
rooks yeah looks very very very
difficult at this point I think it's
about finding practical chance
absolutely it's not about training you
cannot go out there should be selling
because this should be seven there g2
policy in g2 is hanging and so yeah so
rookie what is the idea a knight CDE
might be a knight c3 one is a
possibility yes but regardless this
bishop comes to b7 and the rooks are are
going to be raking through the white
position here absolutely
so perhaps this is possible chances
let's take a look at other games to see
what so we have Eric Hansen against
Wesley so here so before just play by
Wesley here and he's trying to weaken
the d4 square and now take on d65
let's see so it captures e5 I think the
this this looks pretty comfortable for
black
I don't see any major issues here all
blacks pieces seem reasonably happy and
I was to open the West is considering to
take taking on c3 of course yeah and
also he's trying to see which way he
should take on the e5 take with the
knight or take with a pawn perhaps yeah
I think context might actually be
slightly more natural yes it doesn't
look like there are any problems here so
[Music]
Wesley uh thinking about various good
options but I don't think Eric is really
putting on too much pressure here at and
also takes time advantage velocity as
you can see it's yeah there was two and
a half minutes something our players
have kind of excelled at that's good
that's very important and then we have
the game of they will look at the laQuan
no I did I think we have not seen the
calmly in sketch so this is Alec want
Liam black against sorry choose we do
see a very strong night on on f5 and
another night is coming to d5 the plan
of Sarich is to play 90 to 93 and put a
knight on d5 if this is not the most
comfortable is this they are putting up
there they're putting a lot of pressure
on us in this match yeah I can see that
we are just somehow not as comfortable
yeah the pressure has risen and the
chairs are kind of rising to the
challenge they are that being said you
know is now playing knight c6 and hoping
to bring his own knights to to some good
outposts on d4 as well as b4 yeah knight
c6 Knight d5 yeah I think simply Queen
d8 and then I'm hoping to survive in
this city we can survive there hand if
rook b2 Rippey - maybe Knight d4 is his
Leon's idea just blocking off this B
file using this night on yourself yeah
because allowing the rook to come in it
will make it very difficult definitely
do anything so the Knights on their own
perhaps but I can deal with but if a
rook gets into the seventh rank or
anywhere in blacks position it's going
to be situation laQuan guess yeah
clearly you can't we can see is livid
uncomfortable he's a minute minute down
on the clock and he's spending some time
he's not a horrible time pressure just
yet but it has to be accurate n shal
absolute tension it has to be very very
accurate here because the knight on a
five is very strong the knight on d5
so it has to make sure he doesn't
blunder anything you definitely cuz it's
a it's a very dangerous position so
should we go back to the guru shook game
against linear to see okay we have some
exchanges here and yes we did think the
circum the deal we left her off here
after Kim B 1 a 5 b 3 was played right
then say i wonder if he could have save
a little time would think be tricking b
to because we do want to have the king
on b2 in this positioning I don't think
b5 was really an immediate threat for
not gonna be one looked a little bit
strange yeah because I think it was a
little bit of time wasted there
sufficient before so why did activate
the bishop in this manner and bring it
through d3 to e4 yeah and it seems like
you know probably the bishop is not as
active as the night and night has the
potential to go ninety six ninety four
so linear wouldn't mind if yeah it's the
best actually h4 plate here I would
expect us to 36 and so what we do you
see okay
force in the trade of the pair of the
rooks and now Greece shook is trying to
press I think definitely this this is
not the advantage Alinea was hoping for
although the C pawn now might might be a
relevant factor yeah no absolutely
creating some contribution we we cannot
afford the rook to land on d2 so I think
the exchange of the Brooks is pretty
force still I think it's just probably
equal just exchange the rooks King see
three o'clock situation we're about a
minute I had on a clock that's good
yeah and I'm just trying to calculate if
there's any immediate pawn breaks for
black after this wreck trade it trades
to probably not I think he wants to go
in ith 509 h5 is the way for him to put
pressure okay I think that's what he
wants to do but then we can we can put a
king on d2 and if Knight a for plate
just play g3 capture captures Knight
goes back to h5 so we see the black King
coming to the Queen side to deal with
the C pawn and perhaps then the white
king will come to the Kings side to deal
with the blighter minor piece and I
think that's the balance that will be
kept and that's probably why this
position looks to be drawn yeah it's
supposed to be drawn let's see if
Fabiano's game
for pong Caleb for ponds yeah this
sacrifice proved to be really and very
strong yet
I think Robbie just underestimated it
unfortunately and it's the sea the sea
for pond that is going to make the
difference here yeah it's got a pretty
clear path through to see 1 square and
almost fob you can find some way to
immediately stop it it's it's going to
be game over yeah we lost upon the roles
on C 3 C 2 I think it's just I agree
it's just gonna be over so we wait under
pressure
yeah under quite a bit of pressure a lot
of pressure we are here I so can do
something I think I actually expect
version to convert that so let's let's
see on this other on the other one yes
they do some magic here let's see well
the six this is looking a slightly
better surfer blaring how's it gonna
defend how did this happen how did this
happen
Wes Wesley did actually okay switch to
page five interesting we didn't look at
that and I say between live and after
the trade he takes on c3 now this B file
is opened up and E six blades is that
does that move actually make sense there
what East six it's strange no I don't I
don't trust this move we should be it's
activating blacks rook kind of for free
yeah buttons and Wesley usage for very
nice edge for to cover the rook to three
ideas and after Knight f4 checkmate is
threatens and erica's has simply ignored
the threat night - G - o 92 years Queen
f7 does it matter
King h7 and I think you also take one
seven with the Queen yeah okay crook g7
takes everything Ruby tree Wow what a
move okay so when g4 Eric was actually
ready for this one but now maybe Queen
h6
just take no taegeukgi for f3 I broke f3
f3 very important yeah you're willing
some I think this is gonna make a huge
one point I think he's gonna probably
win this one erik has got no time as
well
he's got 48 seconds and under tremendous
pressure here there's actually there's a
tactic here at that I cheated a little
bit
Knight takes h3 they
is devastating night xh3 and then if you
take back with my queendom six and jeer
and while Wesley actually does find it a
very impressive course she finds it yeah
Queen a for inspire you want to take
back no you want to take back with the
Queen of course very nice beautiful
beautiful finish
yeah f3 there's actually getting it done
for us lutely
is under quite a bit of pressure but
even if Bobby loses we get we got the
one point coming from here so that's
good so yes investing Wednesday designs
Leslie wins it and that puts us seven
points we're at seven points right now
one and a half points away from winning
this match wait what just happened here
so definite changes you change this year
and I like it too of blacks Knights have
disappeared in exchange huge changes
okay so the night came to d5 and so we
do see this night Kim deny to be for or
like we expected and at well white goes
in for it takes before but not when it's
a nice move
it's always nice to trade the Queen's
after board in this guy because there
are more pieces on the board more
attacking chances yeah so there should
be six and okay so in this position
white has two knights you must keep your
beep on yeah see three ships e5 but in
this case the the two knights now on d5
and f5 or are not actually contribute
six okay could have done 93 okay the
question is if okay but this this
doesn't look so bad anymore well first
of all there this is rook a two-eyed
okay - Bishop b1 he wants to play right
I think that black has you know chances
now
it's not so simple no what if I simply
play baby Bishop III a cookie of so yeah
I wanted to play something like rook v6
in the near future if we can get that's
you know eliminate the C pawn yeah I
want to get rid of the C pawn I also
want to take on b5 inflation D but
what's going on now if we play take take
Andrew Kate - okay
and now you know efficiently one there's
g2 is hanging of course it's your idea
what can you seconds from the Quang
yeah minute 44 Ivan this is I think
going to be the key game lately has
officially drawn brick by the way yet
and then let's pick the game that we
expected sorry money eight dominguez
don't mean yes yeah I mean gets drawn
didn't you okay so we're at seven and a
half right or is what we expected yet
brings Bobby Bobby one point two score
to clinch the match
Bobby stew Bobby crying yeah trying is a
good word yeah all right but this is the
big game so let's see here this is the
one that matters for us so with a draw
here we officially have have equalized
not equal in force for tie at least a
tie in them so we are at seven in half
right now the score is 7 in half we have
a chess brass have to knife 20 half yet
and so with the draw here of course we
moved to eight points the key number to
win the match is 8 and half I'm very
much expects to score a half point out
of four games in the find so you pay
candy wan just giving up this Jeep on
but getting the king in front just like
anything yeah yeah but it is hanging ins
is black better yeah block is just
winning now H bond is just gonna quit
now
well I guess it all depends on the C
pawn right whether or not but I feel
like even with that C pawn I mean I was
gonna sacrifice there should be five and
I can hope to to actually prevent you
from sacrificing this Bishop Bishop g4 I
should be for okay yeah it's not so easy
I should see four yeah I should report
oh I don't like that move I know it's
Bishop c4 ideas laquanda okay so King g6
has been played to step out of Bishop c4
now he actually wants to go to see to
wants to play look see - now if you play
okay
okay so now the H upon doesn't s come up
the board as we expected so Bishop c4
will play Bishop g4 as you were saying
and now H 3 H 2 H 1 and the game should
end I think we're just gonna win now I
think we're just gonna clinch not like
it knight c6 might be an annoying move
actually the idea of 97 to f5 but then I
think we just made the h2 h1 LHH once
made there's no way to stop it spawn I
guess and now Ivan has actually used his
entire time edge yeah and I think it's
just over now okay look yeah Wow wait
means this was not the way to play to
play on I think this is it night at 5
but you're not in time to stop at h1 and
the game the game is over and Queen d1
or yeah Queen h2 as well the bishop on
c2 falls two minor pieces versus two
major pieces not being balanced
fantastic and yeah Ivan will be
resigning shortly and our obvious game
is still in our game but we already win
we already won the man you've won the
match and Fabi has just resigned Bobby
resigned but but we have scored we won
this match two and a half so yeah now
it's eight and a half to three anything
afternoon have we officially won the
match I think Archbishop's at 18 half 18
18 half already
yes so eight and a half is of course the
the score you need to win the match
there are 16 games total so we now have
won a majority of the total games
there's actually four games left to play
in round four and we'll see if we can
run up the score a little bit absolutely
absolutely
lastic fantastic effort Sheila Kwang
yeah that was a toss-up yes he was
actually in trouble I think
but sorry just miss played it that seems
to be the story of the match for for
Ivan series some good positions but then
our players are you sorry yeah I think
so I think that's really cool he's been
had good positions but hasn't scored and
I think Erik now lost
Erik drew against Bobby and Ron was but
I think he's lost so yeah the bottom
courts are having difficulty fuschia
came back and won so we have one loss
Bobby lost unfortunately but of course
version playing very excellent chess in
the process League so far
we do have the results for round three
Lenny and Dominguez draws Alexander
crook Bobby actually goes down to ali
reza firoozeh eivin search falls to liam
Lee and Eric Hanson is defeated by
wesley so bringing our total score to
eight and a half points the magic number
has been reached we have won the match
with one round left to go
fantastic see how many times you can
spar and we have two guys from score two
and a half I believe Lanier and Wesley
yep they're actually getting quite quite
a bit done for us I think we Emily yeah
I'm not totally sure he's playing an
individual but we've scored quite quite
a bit so we have actually been the only
one lagging for today last five let's
put it this way everybody
plus five we have right now six wins
long lost yeah I think so yeah well I
think we're actually due for a break why
don't we come back with round four in
just a few minutes thanks for watching
watch the Cardinals for the Blues what
about after the game heading back to the
hotel would be a major error through the
city and discover the music that gave
the Blues their name at the National
Blues Museum Broadway or stir bar or
even the legendary Blueberry Hill so
whether you love the Cardinals the Blues
or the Blues come play with us you guys
know I can't play this right st. Loup is
always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round four of
the protest League week five of course
this is the st. Louis Archbishop's
facing the Canada chest bras and we have
officially clinched the match my name is
Caleb Denby
I'm here with Grandmaster vara Cobian
and we're taking a yeah taking a victory
lap now yeah I guess the match has
already decided we already have eight
and a half points so that but now it's
still important to get as many points as
possible definitely separate ourselves
from their chest bras yeah make sure we
we finish first
of course the division every point you
score in the match goes towards your
total score in the division and so we'll
be looking to score some more points
here in the final round in order to give
us a little bit of an extra buffer
against all these other teams absolutely
it's been very very well played match so
far we were under some pressure in the
last match you know but things went on
when our way we won the difficult
position of the Quan head against savage
we turned that difficult potential loss
to a win in Dallas that was the the real
team yeah so now the the chest bras
still just finding to score some points
in the final round well we're we're
looking to extend the lead why don't we
take a look and see what our final round
pairings are actually going to look like
of course for the chest bras we have
Alexander Grichuk on board one against
Bobby Cara wanna our board one ali reza
firoozeh
faces Lenny a Dominguez on board to
board three is Wesley so against Ivan
search and on board for we have Liam Lee
against Eric Hanson and I was talking
earlier this is really the round with
the Archbishop's have I've shown because
it's it's the most fair matchup it's
board one against board one forward two
against board two and that's where the
rating discrepancy is heavy favorites
from the other two boards and they both
been playing well Wesley it's just two
and a half two and a half out of three
and on the Quan won the last game I
don't know if you if you remember what
he did in the first game find out I know
he drew his second game won the last one
but the first one if he had won that one
he'd won or drawn that one
with the win he has two and a half so
yet he actually drew in rounds one two
yes two out of three two out of three
not a bad score I think the story of the
match has actually been greased Rick and
firoozeh are kind of getting the job
done on the first two boards holding a
board woman - they're keeping pace but
they've thrown four aware that arch be a
rockin up a lot of a lot of wings on a
three and four and that's you know
that's that's the key that's everything
absolutely in this match absolutely so
so we're about to see the last round and
again we already have eight in half so
we put us at ninety one and a half right
so we'll get ten points for winning the
match and then we also already have
eight and a half points in the match so
if the match ended right now our score
would go to a hundred even and they
would go to what everyday if they have
three and a half points 70 so they would
go to 88 and a half and so we would have
kind of an 11 and a half point lead
going into these final two rounds but of
course the bigger the lead the better
and it'll take a lot of pressure off of
us if we have a substantial lead after
this week once again we have already
played the marshals and the unicorns and
the Chicago wind with so our final two
rounds are against the Krakens and the
capybaras two teams which have not had
the most success so far she's got the
wind that will qualify if it ended right
now they would qualify I believe so
I believe the 13th team is one of those
three fifth place teams in each division
there and it's done by performance
ratings so the wind has a substantially
so we won't have a bye and who else
would have a buyer so right now it'd be
1st place in each division gets it's a
first round bye
so the the chest oh then it leaves nine
teams and then the the Chicago okay yes
so that makes the the ten teams that's
the house that's even so the round has
actually just gotten far right so why
don't we take a look at this white
against Fabiano
and he started with Knight f3 all right
so now maybe the chest bras we might see
them switch to a slightly more
conservative approach just doing some
damage control making sure they get
enough point
in in this match yeah so 97 yeah the
matches decided that you know so so this
is this 97 is interesting move played by
Fabi he's actually uh we've seen him do
this earlier in the process leaked it
it's kind of a strange-looking move
order but it transposes to some very
common lines yeah okay so c6 and game
wants to counsel and probably age six
would be useful move to play in this
position but it Quinn only seven yeah of
course in this position that the dark
squared Bishop for white sometimes has
some trouble finding finding the perfect
square so efficiency five is quite
common and trading off on f6 is also not
not super uncommon as well so yeah we
see black with a slight central majority
here and white will be looking to to
pressure it yeah yeah d5 is just number
so maybe 93 but also always have to
watch out for d4 so yet I've always
heard when white fee and kiddos this
Bishop to g2 that's often the key piece
in the position wow so what usually
looks to open up this bishop as much as
possible but II for is perhaps give like
the opportunity to don't expect it but
you know what he's trying to do he's
trying to secure a c4 square for his
nine I see they wanted to play now BT to
and then at some point maybe capture and
they finally put a knight on support
right something in that kind of nature
do you ever see black take on e4 there
that that's the move that kind of came
to my mind well the problem is we have
this d6 Bishop vulnerable so that will
open up the position and then we have a
vulnerable bishop on e6 yeah so I guess
black just not quite ready for the
opening in the defect yeah
Ruki one okay yeah with the plan is just
for why the plan is to play 90 to 94 and
try to put pressure I mean life is a
good mission the dish bones too is a
very good Bishop here definitely it's an
open game now and I mean it's just
there's both pawns are weak I mean d3c
it's my as it seems like if if I can
find a good square for this Bishop on c8
then he'll be doing quite alright yeah
until then it's going to be almost wish
the bishop was on g4 yes slightly
awkward for black to get yeah the rest
of his pieces develop Stage six you
chose to page six first so yeah I guess
she was worried rook e8 some 95 jumps
you know yes I'm some danger in that
especially that night on g5 would be
rerouting to the ephors oh I'm gonna
should goes for it okay he just wants to
get rid of the backward ponent yeah the
pawns gone and perhaps now White's a
little bit more ready to deal with the
opening of the position with Bishop 1gq
and the rookies on open file said 95
potential I think this is it's not
comfortable not comfortable no this is
worse I think Bobby did not equalize
here I think maybe Bishop b4 is Bobby's
idea just to get this Bishop out of the
way of the stevemartina b3 Queen b3
Queen a5 or Queen b6 I wanted to wanted
to play Queen b6 hitting it's the knight
on d4 so maybe that one's a bit better
yeah but yeah
doesn't feel like blacks pieces are
solid I think this is where Fabi should
spend some time yeah that's nice by the
way 96 is a serious strategy yeah you
got to come up with a concrete plan yeah
it's a finish development I think it was
just be too slow perhaps I did not quite
understand why not just play d4 here
yeah d4 it keeps the position closed if
you've said white bishop spaced out of
the game
okay 19 you - I'll go cross 194 Bishop
c7 yeah it seems pretty reasonable to me
but yeah this this opening up in the
position perhaps it's it's not not
what's best for five years so he says he
plays Knight 65 okay
and this move seems seems pretty good at
well super Bishop g4
yeah Bishop g4 also 96 is a good idea
for black just in fact if you play like
b4 I'm not sure if it's a good move but
he can play Bishop g4 right let's say f3
it seems like wait f3 everything is
hanging g-force if I don't you go night
maybe yes maybe that's working maybe
even 96 I don't mind and before the
saying but ok before also 96 could be
played right
I don't know sugar there's 9 DB 5 here
attacking the bishop that looks kind of
annoying kind of slightly dangerous we
should be certain when he can trade and
indeed
is there a move slightly awkward like
night b5 maybe there's a rook e8 then
like consider and then just Ricky 898 we
should be so notably it looks like
Wesley so and eivin search have actually
already agreed to a draw and it is this
round 4 here which that's probably
something that both teams aren't too
unhappy about just decided they just
want to get their team's 1/2 point and
call okay so Wesley was up apartment
I guess all for the draw and okay well
that puts us at 9 points right yeah
like we said that the match has already
been decided so this is a comfortable
way for for both players to make sure
that they're helping out their team a
little bit sure I mean I don't think
Wesley would lose disposition
yeah maybe he could have played for a
bit more but he's up upon so I don't
think he would lose this yeah
alright so let's switch now to the game
of we looked at the iana look at the
obby maybe yeah Persia of course a very
strong player white he's white he's on
offense yes let's see what you played
looks like you played something
uncompromising so he played perhaps he's
looking to score the full point yeah II
for Queen B 2 B 3 well so this Queen
comes to d2 allowing white to Castle
queenside a bit more quickly
she 3 little bit loose now a full
sounder attack 92 covers it Queen h4
renews the threat 95 you see I was
eliminated tonight and a4 is hanging
this looks very comfortable for Linea
Dominguez I have to say all of his
pieces make sense United's coming to f5
and this Bishop on g2 is not a great
piece no Bishop on g2 is blockaded I
mean Clark situation is the only thing
that worries me a little bit I mean I
think his position is absolutely fine
yeah in fact you can just play Knight
ef5 here right Lukie 8 is fine 94099
he's absolutely fine wrong I think it's
the clock you know there is no delay or
there is no increment right here there's
a two-second increment to second
remember and so afternoon that ef5 of
course this night covers the d6 weakness
it also blockades the pawn on f4 and the
white structure is just a little bit
fractured here salindra is trying to
prepare f5 perhaps you yeah so what what
can black do you here I think if if
black wants to Queen f6 yeah
Queen f6 and then and then just bring a
Knight to f5 and your position is so
sixes world plays you have some a5 a4
ideas right rook c8 comes in so yeah I
think everything to play here for to
play for here for a lenio Dominguez I
think he's he's got the edge in this
position absolutely so let's look at it
Liam Lee's game is the final game we
have a take a look at rest assured roar
it is so he's white against Erik
handsome so this was a Sicilian I
believe
some Sicilian here I guess it's villian
defense and Queen g3 now some Bishop h6
ideas the ship g5 as well h4 trying to
in some space the M going for kind of a
King side attack preparing Bishop h6 as
well as maybe Bungie for ideas to come
as well there so there was a repetition
actually equality I want to repeat
interesting it's just trying to get the
maximum he's behind on a clock so
perhaps may be repeating wasn't because
it looked like at least Eric wanted to
the repeat because see I did yeah might
actually not be too late to repeat after
b5 here maybe there's there's still
Queen h4 ideas but instead we see a
three I'm praying for the win playing
for a win alright so okay position is I
think it's it's probably about equal
here okay so Bishop f8
play c5 then Bishop e6 yeah probably
okay see one electric c1 he wants to
capture on b5 twice 90 holding the
claiming the queen is misplaced so Queen
p8 stepping out of the line of sight of
the rook and taking on c4 was 94 and of
course so how do you deal with this
tension between the b5 and c4 upon you
you just let it sit
no he okay captures okay and this is
very night a to trying trying to play
night before yeah putting pressure on
this backwards seasick spawned and it
looks like white has just enough
coverage over c5 to make sure this stays
as a weakness
yeah well that's it's very important
that you cannot play c5 because see if I
was in now night before it's coming up
to put pressure also and if something
ever does happen to the C pawn if it
does come to c5 or it gets captured then
the d5 square is something that looks
very nice for for white this is nice
action night before comes in the night
from before can you know route to
decreed and go to c5 so this is very
nice a comfortable edge for it freely
Emily here absolutely so we have one
result Wesley so drew against Sarich so
we are have it nine points at the moment
yeah so let's take a look at yeah I've
only gotten more awkward for Fabien yeah
well clearly if we can see that clearly
our indications was correct because
ninety five was played bb-8
interesting another Tempe yeah the black
piece is just being pushed about or ten
piece five fits the Queen and Bishop h6
is on the board
devastating stuff staining Bobby might
might just be losing oh yeah yeah tough
day for Fabi looks like yeah a very
tough day got one win against savage but
they looked very clear and now Bishop
age six and if I was hanging taking on
c3 not gonna help Queen c3 and now the
agonal pressure we have maybe Meiji for
for black here totally certain yeah it's
just I mean we have no development
draconian I figure I mean it's it's ugly
it's very very ugly we seen I see oh
thanks c5 and f5 is attacked but I guess
NATO
97 Wow
so how do the tactics work out here 93 I
guess there's 98 think you're just gonna
be your he ate and why does that block
is just about to pounce because the
queen is under attack right I I don't
see what else to do that for blacks 93
is played now 98 rook e8 and simply.a
takes b3 expects and it's two pawns to
the good for Alexander Grisham yeah okay
probably just you know we have to for
some tricks probably yeah Brooke did to
bishops III tricky
yeah a groupie Wow okay it's simply one
ball for that b7 is under attack
d4 trying to get some activity but it
should be seven it's simply not enough
you should could be played I think yeah
I think this is just winning mission
takes b7 does come on the board a six
might even come to fall as well and
there's there's no way to really add
pressure to this f2 pond despite this
Bishop being on d4
I think Bishop a6 Syrians it's just all
of the pawns are falling and the black
king is actually even weaker than the
White King due to these extra pawns yeah
you know the problem is every trade
every trade is gonna help Bishop c1 just
just securing everything yeah guarding
regarding because if we take on c3 take
take this should be - yeah this is this
is dead last
I think it's safe to say Greg is going
to convert this most likely yeah he will
convert this let's move on to the other
game that see how yeah I still very much
like líneas position here he sacrificed
a pawn so we saw OH so this beam comes
out to be four and takes on b7
kind of a so you could have played b6
yeah he didn't have to sacrifice but he
thought okay I can sacrifice I think I
agree with them in fact in a tree right
so yet now securing the d4 square very
important hearing the d4 square right
now
now it's white to move in this position
and I'm not sure they're still two
minutes behind then you're is two
minutes behind
all right o'clock I think Lynnea it has
been the kind of a slow mover of the
Archbishop's okay Kim can take on me
take on b3 a - yeah mmm it's starting to
look starting very interesting very
interesting
so a takes b3 of course C takes b3 is
force yeah it is made in the road okay -
captures rook a check kink be walking b1
then win a one check a queen a one I
thought even rook a one with the idea of
rookie - yeah and that's gonna be good
I'm 93 check there yeah minutes
it's gotta go for it right he's gotta go
for it I think is there any okay maybe
it's not completely clear but he's got
well well I think the other thing money
I could do here is just kind of sit on
the position I don't know if he's in a
huge rush to break through immediately
moves like 93 also seemed to be pretty
possible immediately only thing I'm
worried about like queen bee for this I
want like okay I want to get I want a
concrete way to make sure yeah I have
this diagonal because I think if you
don't take right away there's a chance
that he will take on a five and put a
knight on d4 just to shut down that idea
right so this might be a moment do it
now so a B 3 C B 3 rook a to is the
sacrifice you're looking at King gate -
okay a check King B 1 and then we're
looking at a few things there
Queen a one check King see to it 993
check the incomes D to the yeah detail
maybe and now he trees hanging
at night XD 1 rupee 61
okay to check looks like just it doesn't
quite work in the e1 right look like it
works interesting stuff for sure
and so 93 immediately the problem is is
Queen d4 is there anything we can we can
do about that
or maybe so okay what are you worried
about if I just play simple move like
Oryx c5 what is y going to do to
consolidate perhaps maybe just take on
that five Knight takes a five and play
like 94 so we do see a b3 so okay I
think Pharaoh has to take back he
recaptures and now what's the idea oh
the problem is there's no time there has
to go for it otherwise allow it 12
seconds 2 to 5 minutes he has to make a
decision right now anyway he goes for it
okay so King takes a 2 is is a mus it's
a master - Enrique check King be one in
either rookie a1 or Queen a1 we're
considering Queen e1 king c2 rook c8
check King d2
yes sir Rick a 1 was immediately played
and now there's 93 but King d2 is what
we worried about and maybe well we get
we got here what if we just yeah we
couldn't we couldn't find the
continuation and yeah money a is
spending the remainder of his time he
plays 93 with one second on his clock
and and I don't see it I think white is
might might actually just be winning
here you know the 91 White's up a piece
okay rock a - I guess Bishop C - might
be fire yeah it's something 85 maybe I
just have Queen 24 yeah it's gonna be
hard to save this one okay so King III
instead but now Queen h4 trying to get
at the King from the other side but I
think there's just enough pieces are on
the way King
in fact maybe white can get away with
playing something like like Queen b8
checking and taking on on d66 yeah or
perhaps or d2 might be an okay move just
consolidate e2 consolidating and now
taking on d6 cuz then he's gonna start
to generate his own pets yes and there's
on parrots after Queen b6 that's kind of
the key when a sacrifice has been played
like this you want to yes one
consolidate but also start creating your
own threats so you don't have to be on
the defensive for quite so long
so yeah here we see Queen d6 and Wow
rook e1 is trying to create some threats
I guess Queen h3 is the idea and you
can't play Bishop f3 do tonight f5 but
I'm not sure it's even a concrete threat
to be honest with you I think that the
White King is Victoria is escaping okay
- now yeah Rick Rick a - threatens
checkmate and and I don't think black
has actually made a significant threat
with this rook e1 move so white simply
has time to create his own threats while
Queen g5 allows this check but now Queen
g3 is playable and yeah this Queen wants
to see - but this is desperation that
there if anyone is saying you know this
game is over
tough tough one what's so chic actually
Walnut Creek has defeated Fabi and
firoozeh has defeated bunny a and we
have a half point out of three in the
final rounds not quite what we were
looking for thing we had it secured yeah
good thing we haven't think we had a
security issue with that in mind though
I think Liam Liam is gonna quant yeah
he's gonna win yeah we did see this
night this is like the ideal scenario
for white the knight did get into c5 the
pawn is still backwards on c6 which
pressure on e5 and what controls the
entire D file a lot is going well here
for Liam Lee and now a4 is putting some
pressure on the b5 pawn
definitely I cannot go away five yeah
you have to take this I think so B takes
a four
I guess tonight a four and she's sick so
changing and c6 is a problem yeah how do
you defend it
I guess Bishop these never be your be
seven or d7 it's so very very annoying
position yeah and now with the AF I'll
open you might even see one of the white
rooks start to smell that's absolutely
moves like b5 can also become a threat
from white at some point yeah absolutely
if the queen is unprotected you play b5
b6 yeah and plant a bomb on their
abdomen that's close to gaming name so
Queen b8 and we can take c6 but then I
guess Bishop d7 is is blacks idea so
when I see five of course it's not fun
Bishop e2 and the rerouting the Bishop
to c4 oh yeah it's after measuring h5 is
not hanging kind of annoying for white
that this pawn has been pushed all the
way to age five yes would be nice
together like wow what is what is this
okay ninety five is attacking just take
it twice just take twice yeah it's just
waiting do you want its protect it right
and now that the queen is hidden before
these two pawns are worth far more than
just b5 Winnick b5 b6 the only thing is
before I guess to watch out for yeah I I
don't fully believe in it
so b5 I guess II for is now maybe f5 has
to be played there's nothing else two
seconds for Eric I find with under a
second on the clock we see the bishop d5
check it and now yeah b5 does come and
this Bishop stays in the game not
getting locked out by e4 so III is the
move to a child here
I think night a4 makes some sense to
prepare b6 but I guess you do have to
have a response to e3 praise you said so
what's the way you keep the grip on the
position how do you this is the trick
yet I mean you black plate basically the
only thing he had I don't know if we had
to play this move Bishop before I feel
like we could have just played b5 yeah
my plan was when he thought I was just
gonna take everything I play queen c5
and just b6 rights just sucking away the
game now wait but I mean g3 which yeah
f4 is the natural response but no Queen
g6 and after e3 I guess Eric is looking
to checkmate
okay and perhaps this gets the job done
there's a check on V six or a seven but
simply King f1 there's no more checks ea
just hanging and now I mean any number
of moves wins this one's the game Queen
d6 it's the rook just just for a holiday
no now the Prince comes to c5 and where
it can support the push of these pawns
yes you gotta watch out for f3 okay so
night f2 now we can play g4 there's no
LightSquared checks we cover all the
squares b6 and b7 she's coming at any
moment Rickey one first speaks yeah we
see a desperate sacrifice but simply
takes room takes Knight takes it's all I
thought is actually there's no checks
yeah of course the knight a perfect
defender for the cares no chicks
there's no checks here tonight they live
to go to everything and resignation but
I won't Liam Liam Lee has been an MVP
with two wins and two draws rolls very
key matchups so that brings the the
total final score I believe to ten to
six in favor of the Archbishop's and why
don't we actually see the final results
here on the screen
yeah on wards one and two like we said
the Chesbrough David delivered he'll do
it in this round they did their job
they beat Fabiano Carolina and Lenny
Minges no easy feat Wesley so drew Ivan
search and then Liam Lee on board for
that's been the story all day boards
three and four going in our direction so
we get twenty points right defeating
here census yeah we are getting one C
total points at a dryer scourge brush
we'll get six the chess pros will get
six of course that 10 point bonus for
winning the match and this will catapult
us into the lead in the division
standings so 10 to 6 the final score for
the archbishop's over the chess bras
perhaps we can take one more look at the
current division standings and and see
where we actually stand after today of
course 20 points for us slowing point is
huge and again it was it was very very
important yeah so here we have the
Division standings this is what they
were coming into today so 101.5 yeah 20
points for us Ross will be at 91 so we
still have over 10 point lead so we will
have a 10 point lead now this could this
lead could disappear if we slip up in
these finals you know we do have to keep
winning these matches but it's safe to
say if maybe we're next two matches yeah
Everywhere's even with the not a huge
margin we should because we'll be yeah
yeah so a lot to look forward to so in
these last two weeks left yeah just need
to stay consistent up to that magic
number eight and a half and every week
and every week to win the match will be
Western Division champions well for any
final thoughts on the games today I
thought it was a very exciting match and
I think we started really well
especially first to match it with a
really well yeah the third and four I
think they started to put more pressure
on us and you know we got a little bit
lucky I think in that one game that
laQuan Leon won against savage and that
actually turned everything around I was
like Brett it was already over but they
they proved to be very strong opponents
yeah we expected as much from the show
he's deliberately the last match last
round put a lot of pressure but I think
with first two round huge wins with each
one I think there was never a doubt that
we starting off 62 is always going to be
a very difficult mountain
pass and again very difficult for the
trespass because in the bottom boss they
did not yeah
words three and four there's what
actually having time it only scored one
out of eight Wow yeah that's that's not
enough to to win a match yeah they
scored half point for Saudi HR for a
drink yes so congratulations to the st.
Louis are special to look winning this
for modulation we do have some exciting
upcoming broadcasts here at the st.
Louis chess club so next week we will
actually not be broadcasting the
protests League because we do have the
Karen's Cup it is of course a ten player
round-robin with $180,000 up for grabs
in the prize fund it is some of the top
female players in the world including
women's world champion
Zhu Ben Jun will be in this tournament
along with some of her closest
competitors in in woman's chest as well
that'll be running from February 6th to
17th with round one starting on February
7th those rounds start at 1:00 p.m. each
day and of course the final round of the
regular season for the pro chess league
is actually on the same day as the
potential playoffs for the Karen's cup
that is the 17th of February so if there
are no playoffs in the Cairns Cup expect
to see us back here covering our top
four boards hopefully again in the final
round of the of the pro chess league if
there are Karen's Cup Playoffs
well you'll want to stay tuned for that
as well because that'll be very exciting
stuff so thank you all very much for
joining us here for this week's coverage
of the protest league the Archbishop's
get it done again going home champions
against the chest press so be sure to
tune in for the cans Cup coming up very
soon later in February alright thanks
for watching
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club